rescatar lo que las lluvias torrenciales
no llevaron en la región del baluchistán
al oeste de pakistán los habitantes
están agotados
es muy triste que todas mis pertenencias
están sumergidas mi casa inundada muchas
partes de mi casa están dañadas estoy
preocupado mis hijos tienen hambre y
están enfermos a mí me duele qué debo
hacer
entraba mucha agua en nuestro pueblo
nuestras casas están sumergidas algunos
de nuestros familiares han muerto y el
ganado también no estamos recibiendo
ninguna ayuda del gobierno uno de cada
siete pakistaníes se ha visto afectado
por esta temporada de monzones sin
precedentes cerca de 300.000 viviendas
han quedado destruidas numerosas
carreteras han quedado intransitables y
los cortes de electricidad han sido
generalizados las inundaciones han
llegado de todos lados incluso del lado
de irán ahora que la ruta de irán está
cerrada tras las lluvias torrenciales de
ayer en las que se destruyó el puente de
bolan baluchistán ha quedado aislado del
resto de pakistán por carretera
ferrocarril y enlaces de comunicación
frente a la urgencia de la situación el
papá francisco llamó a la ayuda
internacional quiero expresar al pueblo
de pakistán afectado por unas
inundaciones de proporciones desastrosas
mi cercanía preso por las víctimas por
los heridos por los desplazados esa
generosa solidaridad internacional
vendrá pronto dijo ya ti
siempre que sea pronto la generosa
solidaridad internacional los
responsables paquistaníes atribuyen
estas devastadoras inclemencias al
cambio climático afirmando que pakistán
sufre las consecuencias de prácticas
medioambientales irresponsables en todo
el mundo